you said uh the most dangerous person in
the world is a man who's broken and
alone
what do you mean by that
well first off let me just acknowledge
uh I I was I had shutters go down my
spine when I saw that my book was coming
out the same book as Richard's book I
think that guy is amazing yeah
and uh I have been feeling and seeing
this notion of how poorly young men are
doing I just can see it in my friends
with their songs I have friends who have
two daughters and a son and I'm saying
this metaphorically but Loosely speaking
the daughters of Penn the younger
daughters working at PR firm in Chicago
and the sun is in their basement vaping
and playing video games
young men
a seven to ten high school
valedictorians or girls for every one
male college graduate over the next five
years there's going to be two female
college graduates
93 of mass Shooters are men three times
more likely to overdose four times more
likely to commit suicide 12 more times
more likely to be incarcerated they do
worse in single-parent households for
some reason girls have the same outcomes
in a dual parent household versus a
single we have more single parent
households our education system is
biased against men men on a
behavior-adjusted are boys on a behavior
adjusted voices are twice as likely to
get suspended for the same infraction as
a girl two-thirds to 80 percent of all
primary and secondary teachers are are
women and understandably they're going
to Champion little girls who they see
themselves in so young men just have the
deck stack against them if you walk down
the Avenue that is America
one in three men under the age of 30
will not have had sex in the last year
and people hear the word Saxon their
brain fires different ways but sexism is
a key step to the elemental Foundation
of any society and that's a relationship
and then you you rap and covet you rap
in the biological
fact that men's pre-fertile cortex
doesn't evolve as quickly they're more
immature and then you have all this
these this kind of short form ability to
get similar dopa of relationships on
social similar dopa that you're learning
or or get or taking risks with Robinhood
or gambling you're not learning you're
not investing you're gambling and it's
fun but it's gambling you don't have to
put on a shirt or figure out the skills
to meet women because you can get some
of that hit by watching porn
I mean what's your motivation to go out
and go through the humiliation of dating
to get to your own sex when you get a
sort of a reasonable facsimile of it at
home what's your what's your rationale
for working hard and delaying
gratification when you keep keep seeing
these screenshots of men who've made
twelve thousand percent return on Solana
so and men are good at executive
functions they're kind of two years
behind an 18 year old boy applying to
college is sort of on par with a 16 or a
17 year old girl or put another way did
you see uh Paige Harden published a
study looking at the
um comparative levels of impulse control
between boys and girls so you can
imagine there's a graph over time in
terms of impulse control the time is
going along the bottom you've got two
lines that are both male and female for
a male to have the same level of impulse
control as a 10 year old girl
they need to be 24.
yeah the the Delta I've heard that's
striking the Delta I've heard is two
years but even if you think about two
years
you basically if you have two 18 year
old people applying to college
basically the 18 year old is competing
against a 16 year old
so imagine imagine you're in 10th Grade
applying to college and all the girls
are in 12th grade
that's that's what we're facing right
now and at NYU I can tell you that some
of the schools there if they were
totally applicant blind it would not
only be predominantly female they'd be
70 Asian female I mean the Asian
Community has been so successful in our
society as it as it comes to producing
traits and behaviors that colleges love
and people think well okay if if men if
men are finally not doing very well I
mean we basically we level the playing
field about an education and what we
found is women just absolutely blew by
yeah man because absolutely blew by and
you think well what's the problem with
that well when it was 40 60 female to
female to male we decided to do
something about it with Title IX and
affirmative action and we leveled up
women now that it's 40 60 or you could
even argue 3366 in terms of graduation
because men grad drop out the question
is well are we concerned now and the the
knock-on effect here is that
getting a college degree is still a
really good plan B for Economic Security
on average over the course of your
lifetime a college grad will make about
double what a non-college grad makes
and so what you have is women mate
socioeconomically horizontally and up
men horizontally and down
the bottom line is women with college
degrees aren't interested in mating with
men without college degrees
so you have this what I'll call Porsche
polygamy effect
and that is when you take the Chaser of
online dating which is doing the same
thing that technology does to every
sector is consolidating it and creating
a winner take most environment the top
10 percent of men in terms of
attractiveness on Tinder get 80 90 of
the swipe rights they get they get all
of the attention which quite frankly
doesn't lead to a lot of great Behavior
you know too much opportunity is not
necessarily a good thing the 50 to 90
percentile in terms of attractives from
men do okay in the bottom fifty percent
are just totally shut out
and what happens to these men who are
totally shut out for mating
opportunities they lose confidence they
start becoming much more prone to
misogynistic content with these internet
celebrities telling them it's not their
fault it's a woman's fault
they become less likely to believe in
climate change they become more
nationalist I mean young men are very
good at blaming other people when things
aren't going well for them and so what
are the most violent dangerous societies
all have in common they all have a
disproportionate number of the most
dangerous person on the planet a young
broken alone man and we're just
producing way too many of them and we
can't even have an honest conversation
about it because the moment you start
evangelizing for young men the moment
you're seen as quote unquote pro- young
man
the natural assumption is that means
you're
anti-women because admittedly there's
some guys out there on Tick Tock
claiming to be trying to give men
confidence
that basically it's basically thinly
veiled misogyny yes referring to women
as [ __ ] and you gotta own the [ __ ]
and you got to get out there take my
class for 49 a month and you'll get the
money and put the [ __ ] in their place
you're like Jesus Christ that's what
young men are are susceptible to it's
really it's it's dangerous and it's ugly
so I think a lot about masculinity I
think we need I think the left needs to
take back masculinity
and one of the things I enjoy doing on
my podcast I'm a profane vulgar person
and for some reason profanity and
vulgarity has been conflated with some
sort of non-progressive person no it's
not comedians who've been really profane
and vulgar tend to be more Progressive
masculinity is a wonderful thing it's
not necessarily the domain of
people-born men but advocating for
others protecting others using skills
and strengths to protect other people
you know being aggressive that is a
wonderful thing when when Russians come
pouring over the Border in Ukraine you
want some of that big dick energy
masculinity is a wonderful thing and it
should be embraced and to conflate
toxicity and masculinity is bad for
society and we've gotten to a point
where we don't value young men we're not
giving them as many opportunities as
we're giving older Generations much less
other young women and it's a I think
it's an existential crisis for United
States and you know who wants more
emotionally economically viable men
women
and women have a much finer filter for
mating than men
and they're just not finding that many
good young men they're just we aren't
producing enough of them it doesn't
surprise me that it's a confusing
situation to be in men are being told to
both man up and open up but to avoid
being toxically masculine but when you
see the
revealed preferences versus stated
preferences of the way that women date
that guys should get over their fear of
tall women when Zendaya and Tom Holland
got into a relationship together it's
like I I don't think that short guys
were turning down Zendaya I think that
it's the other way around on average
women want a partner that's 21
centimeters taller than them on average
men want a partner that's 16 centimeters
shorter than they are so I all of that
is something that everyone listening to
the show will be very familiar with this
mating crisis that we're seeing at the
moment is something that I've been very
passionate about
something that Richard taught me about
last week when I was on the show is
young male syndrome why have we not got
these swaths roving gangs of young
disaffected youths youth guys pushing
over granny and causing havoc and stuff
like that
that hasn't happened that that just
doesn't seem to be happening yes you've
got School shooters they are individual
groups yes the salmon Rishi thing again
as well was also an individual loan
actor probably somebody that had been
more integrated into a family and into
his local community would have been less
likely to commit that sort of an act
but we haven't seen it on mass in the
same sort of way you correct with what
you say between 2008 2018 men went from
eight percent to 28 the number of men
that haven't had sex in the last year
however
we haven't seen this proliferation of
young male syndrome occurring and
Richard's contention was that
the fake Fitness cues that you're
getting from technology are sedating men
they're repurposing some of that energy
that they would have put into being very
aggressive out into the world and as
opposed to us going out with a bang
we're going out with a fizzle
and from what I see the sort of rhetoric
that I hear online from Men
it is a lot less I'm going to go out and
do something about this it is a lot more
I'm going to retreat in to me just hold
on tight boys the sex robots are coming
soon like these are non-ironic comments
that I see on the internet so I think
this is a bit of availability bias
because it's something new that I've
just learned about so I'm all excited
about it and it seems to explain stuff
but I do think that there is a very good
argument to be made that you're not
going to end up with dangerous men
you're going to end up with the useless
man
I think that's fascinating what's
happening people if you enjoyed that
then press here for the full unedited
episode and don't forget to subscribe
peace
[Music]